les enseignants encore en grève cette
fois dans les écoles primaires et les
collèges le mouvement a été assez
largement suivi le franc est il en
danger sanist à nyon aussi les réponses
de raymond barre qui est notre invité le
venezuela en état d'urgence dix ans
après le boom pétrolier le gouvernement
a du mal à imposer l'austérité
vingt ans déjà
c'est aujourd'hui l'anniversaire de
concorde et on prépare son successeur
prog et proxénétisme le commissaire joe
big est une coupable
ouverture de son français aujourd'hui à
nanterre madame monsieur bonsoir
les pays riches sont de plus en plus
riches c'est ce que constate cette année
les experts de l'osce et des oeufs
cette espèce d'observatoire de
l'économie mondiale mais les pays
pauvres
étranglés par leurs dettes ont d'autant
plus de difficultés à décoller que
certains ont cru au miracle
c'est le cas du venezuela où c'est un
dernier bilan
plus de 200 personnes sont mortes dans
les émeutes de ces derniers jours
le calme est maintenant revenu en
province mais à caracas la capitale
la situation reste instable philippe
lefait
voici à quoi ressemble les rues de la
capitale d'un pays où il n'y a plus
aucune miette de la croissance a
redistribué les pillards les miséreux et
les soldats face à face l'armée kadri
caracas et dix mille soldats de
l'intérieur du pays ont été appelés en
renfort
malgré un semblant de calme et le couvre
feu de nouveaux affrontements la nuit
dernière ont fait plusieurs dizaines de
morts
face à l'afflux de blessés par balles
les hôpitaux manquent de sang et
d'instruments de chirurgie les
supermarchés épargné par les émeutiers
sont sous protection rapprochée
la subite réapparition des marchandises
n'a pas calmé semble-t-il la grogne de
celles et de ceux qui patientent pour
remplir un panier et dans les
entreprises
beaucoup d'ouvriers mentale embauches
faute de transports ou presque classique
le gouvernement cherche à éteindre la
cendre les prix des produits
indispensables ont été gelés et les bas
salaires augmenter de quelques bolivar
nous sommes dans un pays modèle de
démocratie où le ministre de la défense
déclare l'armée ne peut tolérer le
désordre
comment expliquer une telle violence un
tel désespoir dans l'un des pays qui
paraissait jusqu'ici parmi les mieux
lotis de l'amérique du sud
eh bien il ya dix ans le venezuela
s'enflammait pour le pétrole et ses
richesses
aujourd'hui il dit sous la dette
michel mompontet 1979 caracas les
vertiges de la fortune pour les pays de
l'opep le baril de pétrole s'envole
alors jusqu'à 35 $ pour de nombreux pays
dont la plupart sous développés c'est
une richesse inespérée l'assurance d'une
rente colossal leur pétrole vaut
désormais six fois plus cher
1986 c'est la fin du mirage le
retournement de situation sommet de
vienne le baril s'écroule 15 dollars
parfois moins encore
entre ces deux dates les cruelles
désillusions de pays qui s'étaient crus
définitivement riches
parmi eux le venezuela quatrième
producteur mondial de pétrole
1979 l'argent coule alors à flot le
litre d'essence ne vaut ici que 30
centimes la consommation s'emballe mais
on ne consomme qu'à l'étranger aucune
infrastructure industrielle n'est alors
mises en place
ce pays devient tout à coup le plus gros
importateur du monde de télévision et de
voitures de luxe ont construit aussi
mais surtout pour le prestige
quand en 1986 le prix du baril chute ce
pays qui levait largement au dessus de
ses moyens sans dette sans dette dans
des proportions considérables durant dix
ans seulement un vénézuélien sur dix a
profité des largesses de l'or noir
si dans ces bidonvilles chacun a
désormais une télévision la misère n'a
pas pour autant reculer pas question
d'aller à genève discuter avec l'iran
c'est ce qu'on répétait à l'envi
aujourd'hui les officiels britanniques
il avait reçues semble-t-il de discrets
appels du pied de téhéran pour ouvrir le
dialogue
la france de son côté serait en train de
freiner ses importations de pétrole
iranien de façon à conforter la
solidarité occidentale dans la sphère
rushdie et de trois grèves des
enseignants aujourd'hui pour la
troisième fois depuis le début des
négociations entre lionel jospin et
leurs syndicats
cette fois ci c'était au tour des écoles
primaires et des collèges le mouvement a
été assez largement suivi même si les
chiffres diffèrent comme d'habitude
selon les sources un peu plus de la
moitié des instituteurs en grève selon
le ministère
plus des deux tiers selon le sc nice qui
ont donc fait les enfants aujourd'hui
chantal qui perd là a passé la journée
dans une école primaire à levallois pas
de métier aujourd'hui ancien de fautes
d'instituteur et d'élèves
cinq enseignants sur 15 ans primaire ont
fait grève et l'école maternelle est
resté totalement fermé 50 % des
enseignants absents
une grève moyennement suivi est jugé par
les non-grévistes malvenu je ne fais pas
grève parce que je pense que
ya trop de grèves en ce moment que ça
pollue beaucoup d'impact sur le
gouvernement mais par contre je suis
complètement solidaire et je compte
faire la manifestation samedi une grève
qui n'a pas perturbé l'école et qui
somme toute fut bien accepté enfants et
parents font preuve de la plus grande
compréhension
qu'est ce que c'est la grève tu sais gré
fonctionnaires alors je sais de quoi
quoi quoi ils veulent par les promeneurs
et vous estimez qu'il faut préserver le
droit de grève chez les enseignants bien
sûr ça va de soi à tout prix samedi
matin ce sont les lycées qui connaîtront
des grèves et sa douce et une
manifestation plutôt trois
manifestations convergentes
à paris michèle droit va-t-il être
inculpé d'homicide involontaire
l'académicien journalistes attendant le
nord du cameroun
la décision du procureur local qui l'a
entendu aujourd'hui je vous le disais
hier la partie de chasse à laquelle il
participait à bien mal tourné puisque
son compagnon jacques rené chypre et en
est mort pascal deschamps nous en ait
plus
c'est ici dans la réserve du pharo que
l'accident s'est produit
vraisemblablement au moment où les
chasseurs s'apprêtait à tirer un lion le
terrain était difficile explique michel
droit je suis tombé mon fusil m'a
échappé et le coup est parti
la carabine de calibre 460 est l'armé de
chasse la plus puissante au monde selon
un armurier quand le fusil et armés même
si la sûreté et mise tout peut arriver
où peut se passer lors d'une partie de
chasse surtout dans des terrains c'est
broussailleux et naturellement si en
plus une personne pont et peut y avoir
une branche qui a accroché la sûreté on
a mis en position feux voyez signe
rousies cycladique en ce moment là si on
pousse sur la détente beaucoup partir
reconstitution et interrogatoires se
succèdent depuis hier un gars ou modérée
selon les gendarmes
l'accident ne fait guère de doute mais
en attendant la décision judiciaire
michel droit a été prié de ne pas
quitter le pays une autre histoire de
savane plus incroyable encore une
histoire d'éléphants sous deux
villageois sont morts dans le népal une
bande d'éléphants sauvages avaient vidé
des bronches de liqueur ils ont mis le
tout un village à sa qui tu es donc de
personnes venons en à la politique est
d'abord à ses propos reproduits par le
magazine l'expansion et qui agit
le microcosme monsieur bart bonsoir vous
qui n'aimez pas les petites phrases et
qui égratigne et volontiers le
microcosme voici que selon des
journalistes fort sérieux il faut
préciser on vous prête une analyse très
sévère de la politique économique du
gouvernement
une politique qui auriez-vous dit risque
de faire sauter de france est ce que
vous pensez
non madame de deux précisions
d'abord ce sont pas ce ne sont pas des
déclarations que j'ai faites
j'ai eu une conversation sur le
symposium international de davos et j'ai
vu trois semaines après paraître une
interview de moi avec des questions et
des réponses des questions que je
n'avais pas vu et des réponses qui m'est
fait prêter alors jeune j'avais menti
parce que je ne prends pas à mon compte
ce qui ne vient pas de moi et il ne
m'est pas soumis pardon oui pardon sur
le fond alors j'en viens au fond on peut
bien imaginer que certains aspects de la
politique récente du gouvernement je
pense notamment au récent accord entre
le ministre de la santé et les médecins
hospitaliers par exemple est-ce que ça
n'entretient pas chez vous une certaine
crainte de dérapages dans la politique
de rigueur
madame jour vient précisément au fond ce
qui compte à mes yeux c'est que dans le
climat inflationnistes international qui
est en train de se préciser
la france puisse échapper à dérapage
inflationniste et que le fonds puisse
être maintenue ce qui est essentiel en
système monétaire européen
à l'heure actuelle nous constatons que
sur le plan budgétaire après le vote du
budget le gouvernement a décidé de geler
10 milliards de francs de crédits et
qu'il laisse entendre que si besoin
était il procéderait à une révision de
ses dépenses budgétaires
cela va dans le sens du maintien de la
stabilité du franc en ce qui concerne la
monnaie la politique du crédit les
normes de politique monétaire sont
respectées si j'ai une inquiétude c'est
en ce qui concerne la croissance du
crédit à la consommation
en ce qui concerne les rémunérations les
rémunérations augment dans le secteur
privé de manière modérée dans le secteur
public il y a eu une série d'ajustements
dont nous ne savons pas exactement
quelle sera l'incidence sur le budget je
crois que tous ces problèmes devront
être étudié dans les mois à venir mais
il ya une chose qui est fondamental
c'est que pour maintenir la stabilité du
franc
tout devrait être fait dans le domaine
du budget de l'amener des rémunérations
de telle sorte que notre pays puisse
bénéficier d'une monnaie stable
voilà ma position et cela n'a rien à
voir avec des petites phrases qui sont à
la fois sommaire et d'irresponsables
car s'il ya une chose que je n'ai jamais
fait c'est de parler en termes léger de
l'avenir du franc toujours sur le fond
monsieur bart en juin 88 vous aviez dit
concernant l'ouverture la fameuse
ouverture il faut laisser du temps au
temps
après les propos de françois mitterrand
à 7 sur 7 est ce que vous pourriez
redire cette phrase ou est ce qu'il ne
faudra t'il pas plus de temps au temps
ce mais je n'ai pas été étonné par les
propos du président de la république
faisant appliquer réélu il a nommé un
gouvernement
ce gouvernement dispose à son du
national d'une majorité relative
la constitution d'un cinquième
république a été fait pour que l'on
puisse gouverner dans une telle
situation notamment grâce aux 49 alinéa
3 par conséquent le gouvernement
gouverne
l'ouverture c'est une décision du
président de la république c'est à dire
que s'ils désirent la faire et à un
moment qui lui paraîtra nécessaire alors
il faudra que l'ouverture ne
n'apparaissent pas simplement comme une
série de ralliement et peut-être de
reniement mais que cela apparaisse comme
une politique voulue par tous ceux qui
seraient prêts à travailler dans le sens
de l'intérêt national
alors ne vivons pas constamment dans cet
état d'esprit que l'ouverture est pour
demain
je crois que aujourd'hui les conditions
sont telles que
président la république et le
gouvernement entendent gouverner avec
les moyens dont il disposait bien qu'ils
gouvernent et que ceux qui sont dans
l'opposition
sache faire preuve à la fois du
vigilance parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
accepter n'importe quoi et doivent
combattre ce qui ne va pas dans le bon
sens mais que toutes les fois que la
politique gouvernementale va dans le bon
sens on ne se livre pas à une agression
une critique systématique et que l'on
adopte une politique constructive
voilà qu'elle a toujours été ma position
et je vous le répète ce soir monsieur
bah il y a une échéance politique que
toute proche et là vous êtes directement
en cause puisque vous êtes numéro deux à
lyon sur la liste du maire sortant
francisque collomb
une liste dont le dernier sondage dont
nous faisions état hier donne
sérieusement à la traîne loin derrière
michel noir du rpr et gérard que l'on le
socialiste claude réjean nous dit le
climat à lyon les vents politiques
lyonnais sont favorables la liste du rpr
hors norme michel noir les mesures de
l'opinion concorde à dix jours du
scrutin cette liste pourrait largement
distancée celle de l'udf conduite par le
maire sortant francisque collomb et par
raymond barre
pourtant michel noir restent prudents en
ce moment les lyonnais sont en train de
faire leur choix
il semble en ce moment frémir en quelque
sorte mais il ya encore une dizaine de
jours
le temps pour les lyonnais de se faire
leur opinion attendant le 12 mars par
avance le leader du rpm lyonnais réfute
toutes velléités hégémoniques sur la
ville une équipe municipale a le souci
de gérer au service de l'ensemble des
habitants de la cité moi je souhaite
gérer la ville de lyon au service de
l'ensemble mais ce n'est pas une affaire
de titeuf
preuve supplémentaire de la vence actuel
de michel noir
le leader de la gauche le choisi comme
cible prioritaire
monsieur noah à ses amis ont été
associés pendant 12 ans au pouvoir
municipal avec des responsabilités
importantes
l'école internationale monsieur noir
lui-même a été à la fois ministre du
commerce extérieur et responsable des
affaires économiques
qu'at-il apporté à la ville de lyon je
crois que les lyonnais veulent davantage
de compétences
je me demande s'ils ne vont pas avoir
davantage d'intolérance l'udf lyonnaise
est en plein désarroi
faute de désignation comme dauphin du
maire sortant
le premier adjoint andré soulier a pris
ses distances au moment où michel noir
valse avec sa mère devant un parterre de
personnes âgées
l'udf risque d'entraîner raymond barre
dans une valse hésitation périlleux
c'est par ce soir vous ne valent sais
pas non madame
et je n'ai pas de pas saisi dation
périlleuse
la réalité est très simple il ya les
sondages que vous avez indiquée
en ce qui me concerne mon ou bio est
très simple je n'ai jamais eu d'ambition
municipales à lyon et depuis douze ans
que j'y suis il y a quelques mois le
maire de lyon va demander de participer
à la viste qu'il conduirait aux
élections municipales
j'ai accepté pour une raison très simple
c'est pour une raison d'amitié pendant
12 ans
le maire de lyon et son équipe ont été
pour moi de fidèles soutiens
je n'ai pas l'habitude quand on me
demande d'aidé les amis
de laisser tomber ce dernier roman est
ce que vous êtes sûr d'avoir choisi la
bonne liste est ce qu'un ticket par
exemple vraiment barre michèle noiret ce
que ce n'était pas quelque chose de
possible mais après tout n'y a pas
beaucoup de différences politiques entre
michèle noiret voulu bien sûr mais vous
constatez que en ce qui me concerne je
dis je me suis livré à aucune agression
je vous précise que j'ai eue hier soir
sous une plume d'ailleurs médiocre que
je faisais une erreur de jugement
soutenant un maire vieillissant c'est
pas le problème pour moi le problème
c'est de soutenir un maire est une
équipe qui ont été pour moi des soutiens
fidèles et ça quelle que soit l'issue
maintenant je constate premièrement que
cette équipe un très beau bilan que
personne ne conteste
deuxièmement que cette équipe a été
renouvelé et qu'il y à des personnalités
diverses et des jeunes qui sont venus
renforcer cette équipe
troisièmement que cette équipe a un
projet et que ce projet va à mon sens
dans le sens des intérêts de lyon et
bien voilà trois conditions que j'avais
cru nécessaire de voir remplies elles
sont remplies il faut attendre le
jugement des lyonnais seulement et sebha
au delà du premier tour impliqué barre
noire est inenvisageable pour le désir
et c'est pas le problème nous ne savons
pas ce qui va se passer au premier tour
j'avais vu plus noir lui-même est
prudent attendons et en 1983 figurez
vous que les chiffres étaient les mêmes
et les résultats ont été différents je
vous dis pas que cette fois ce sera la
même chose il ya peut-être des éléments
nouveaux qui joue mais je crois qu'il
faut attendre le jour de l'élection
c'est à dire le premier tour le
12 mars et puis on verra ce qui va se
passer
nous allons donner du temps au temps
mais mais je crois que dans la vie il
faut être patient et ne pas vivre dans
l'instantané ce qui malheureusement est
quelque chose que l'on doit faire
aujourd'hui avec tous les sondages qui
qui ne cessent de se multiplier
je crois qu'il faut attendre
tranquillement le vrai sondage c'est à
dire le vote des lyonnais et nous en
tirons les conséquences je vous remercie
je ne sais pas vous restez avec après
madame v la personnalité d'opposition
que les français apprécient le plus cela
va peut être vous faire plaisir 46%
d'opinions favorables selon le baromètre
le baromètre sofres figaro magazine
quant à la cote de confiance du chef de
l'état et de son premier ministre
elle reste stable 58% d'opinions
positives pour françois mitterrand 55%
pour michel rocard
le premier ministre était avec l'armée
de terre aujourd'hui au camp de canjuers
éric perrin première visite de michel
rocard à l'armée de terre au camp
militaire de canjuers le premier
ministre accompagné de jean pierre
chevènement s'est prononcé en faveur
d'un muret cas militaire programme
européen de coopération scientifique et
technologique
autre sujet abordé le désarmement et le
service national michel rocard a affirmé
sa volonté d' incorporer un plus grand
nombre de jeunes diplômés
de nouvelles inculpations dans la sphère
des fausses factures de marseille pierre
bentata directeur général de la sas
numéro un français du bâtiment et jean
claude cham président du directoire ont
été inculpées entre autres de ton fait
usage de faux en écriture de commerce
fier bentata le seul des deux à être
placé sous mandat de dépôt nie toute
implication dans cette affaire
reprise du travail sur la ligne a du rer
du moins jusqu'au 14 avril prochain date
à laquelle direction et syndicats se
rencontreront à nouveau en revanche la
grève se poursuit sur la ligne 7 du
métro
importante incendie dans la salle des
machines de la centrale thermique de
champagne sur oise
il aura fallu près de 200 pompiers pour
maîtriser le feu dont l'origine reste
indéterminée selon la préfecture tout
risque d'explosion est écarté concorde a
eu 20 ans aujourd'hui un anniversaire
sans rides que l'on a fêté joyeusement à
toulouse et déjà on prépare le super
concorde le supersonique du futur
patrick esther nous le dévoile des
images longtemps gardée secrète
elle date des essais en soufflerie de
concorde c'était il y a vingt ans une
concurrence sévère opposé européens
américains et soviétiques
des essais qui aboutissent le 2 mars 60
9 au premier vol aux commandes le pilote
d'essai andré turcat son nom fait
maintenant partie de la légende il a le
premier senti frémir l'avion lors du
passage du mur du son aujourd'hui 20 ans
après concorde est le seul avion civil
qui évolue à 2200 km heure aussi vite
que les chasseurs un avion de rêve que
le choc pétrolier a irrémédiablement
condamnées dans l'oeuf
pourtant bien des compagnies savent
qu'il existe une véritable clientèle
fortunée pour ce type d'avion dans les
15 années à venir concordera des
successeurs peut-être la tsf proposé par
les français
avion de transport supersonique du futur
de 100 places
12000 km de rayon d'action plus
silencieux et surtout moins gourmand en
carburant
son secret de nouveaux moteurs un
réacteur fonctionnant avec deux
principes différents vols normal et en
vol supersonique
un système qui doit permettre 30%
d'économies de kérosène une invention
qui aurait pu sauver concorde mais les
études de la tsf coûteront tellement
cher que japonais américains européens
et peut-être même soviétique devront
joindre leurs efforts
une coopération qui préfigure les futurs
grands programmes mondiaux ceux des
avions spatiaux du troisième millénaire
ce qui en porteront leurs passagers à 25
fois la vitesse du son
on y est presque fade la grève des
techniciens thomson csf de kourou en
guyane lancement de la fusée ariane que
la grève avait retardé pourrait avoir
lieu dans les 48 heures
l'ambiance était chaude aujourd'hui au
palais de justice de nanterre c'était
l'ouverture du procès du commissaire
jobic une affaire au plus tôt des
affaires complexe et ambigu qui plonge
dans la pénombre du travail policier
les explications d'isabelle bechler et
emmanuel vanille mon sentiment est
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on va enfin voir
éclater la vérité à savoir que ce aussi
est totalement vide depuis le début et
que nous exclurons aujourd'hui on fait
avoir à faire l'oeuvre justice en gros
au départ en 86 une banale affaire de
drogue
ici dans le port de gennevilliers surnom
de cette cité de transit le supermarché
de la drogue
on y vend une dose d'héroïne toutes les
trois minutes octobre 86 plusieurs bars
parisiens sont mis sur écoute
téléphonique
jean-claude mustapha est arrêté décembre
86 intervention du commissaire jobic
pour le faire libérer
motif il est l'un de ses principaux
indicateurs mais l'insistance du
commissaire trouble le juge hyatt de
nanterre la sphère jobic commence début
87 rue de budapest un quartier de
prostitution parisien où le commissaire
jobic a souvent enquêter les langues se
délient trois prostituées accuse le
commissaire de les racketter novembre 87
le juge hayat un culte yves jobic de
proxénétisme aggravé pour les parties
civiles les témoignages sont nombreux et
concordants
mais selon les défenseurs du commissaire
ces accusations ne sont pas crédibles
elles émanent toutes du milieu des
témoignages que le juge estime lui
suffisamment convaincant pour faire
écrouer yves jobic en juin 88
mais quinze jours plus tard la chambre
d'accusation le remette en liberté sous
contrôle judiciaire depuis yves jobic
attendait donc de comparaître bois et
haute tension dans une salle pleine
comme un oeuf trois prostituées
participé sous escorte 26 prévenus dont
ils jouent aux billes
soixante sept témoins dont une bonne
case et ne s'est pas présenté une
quarantaine d'avocats pour un dossier de
près de dix mille pages le calme jusqu'à
présent imperturbable du président
foulquier a permis de débrouiller
l'écheveau des identités des uns et des
autres mais un incident est révélateur
du climat qui alourdissaient l'audience
aujourd'hui un proxénète actuellement
incarcérées qui doit témoigner à charge
contre yves jobic s'est plaint un très
violemment d'avoir été brutalisé par les
policiers du dépôt du tribunal de
nanterre
il réclame pour venir témoigner
ultérieurement d'être exclusivement
entre les mains des gendarmes avant même
qu'on aborde le fond la guerre entre
policiers et gendarmes
c'est donc surface quoi qu'il en soit
les choses sérieuses commenceront pour
yves jobic jeudi prochain d'ici là le
tribunal correctionnel de nanterre
plante un décor fait de trafic de drogue
et de prostitution
accident de travail pour deux policiers
belges venus arrêter un toxicomane il a
le sida
il saignait il les a mordu et policiers
devront attendre plusieurs semaines
avant d'être rassurés sur leur propre
santé le monde des casinos rappeler à
l'ordre l'ordre et celui du ministre de
l'intérieur qui vient d'en fermer cinq
dont celui de nice et de beaulieu sur
mer
en revanche quelques établissements
conserve l'autorisation d'exploiter
leurs machines à sous hervé brusini
patrice volé au casino de
beaulieu-sur-mer on pratique surtout le
jeu de mains jeu de vilains l'équipe
défaire 3 qui ce matin vous l'êtes
enquêter sur la fermeture de
l'établissement en équipe pour deux
blessés
les temps sont durs pour le monde du
tapis vert fin de partie aussi pour le
casino club de nice
ici comme à beaulieu les autorités ont
considéré qu'il pouvait y avoir
tricherie entendez une certaine
difficulté à connaître l'identité réelle
des bailleurs de fonds des sociétés à
nice par exemple et renseignements
généraux sont persuadés que jean
dominique fratoni se cache derrière son
fils et son gendre qui siège au comité
de direction du casino club jean do pour
les intimes est en fuite
à ses trousses un mandat d'arrêt
international qui fait suite au scandale
du palais de la méditerranée
en tout cinq établissements ont donc été
fermée avec l'assentiment du syndicat
des casinos le dossier machines à sous
en revanche semble plus délicat trois
établissements se sont vu prend roger
leur autorisation pour un an mais on
sait la question des bandits manchots
autres oppose l'actuel et l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur et la partie est
acharnée cette autorisation d'installer
des machines à sous dans les casinos
avait été accordée avait été acceptée
par le ministère des finances et
notamment le ministre du budget pour
compenser le manque à gagner dont il
était victime
la loi pasqua voter ya maintenant deux
ans 87 mise en application
subrepticement alors que mitterrand
avait déjà été élu président la
république
les arrêtés signés au journal officiel
après unitaire de joueurs prennent
accordant à quelques casinos par rapport
à aux 150
ils sont capables de le demander une
quinzaine
je dis que c'est toi et surtout ses
conditions d'application sont suspectes
en fait pierre joxe souhaite
l'abrogation pure et simple de la loi
pasqua
mais la réalité est là de grosses sommes
sont en jeu 350 millions de francs de
recettes pour l'état si les cinq mille
machines à sou prévus sont installés
twickenham samedi prochain tous les
amoureux du rugby seront au rendez vous
pour la rencontre angleterre france
comptant bien sûr pour le tournoi des
cinq nations
une mauvaise nouvelle pour les français
le forfait dallas lorieux le deuxième
ligne blessés on connaîtra son
remplaçant de
préparons-nous en tout cas aux émotions
fortes et saluant déjà avec jean mas
maire serge blanco
la star modeste du quinze de france
blanco ça décape blanco la star blanco
le sportif dont on parle le plus entre
décembre et avril serge blanco pour qui
paris et le monde du rugby se déplace à
biarritz l'ancien ouvrier de chez
dassault devenu aujourd'hui relations
publiques sera sans doute demain un
homme d'affaires avisé dans le tourisme
une ascension grimpantes comme un poteau
de rugby l'eau est ce devenu star un mot
que pourtant il ne veut pas connaître
j'ai un dictionnaire et puis dans mon
dictionnaire est pas mentionnée
j'aime pas trop ce moment là d'une chape
et abstraction je suis un sportif de
haut niveau
j'ai la chance d'évoluer au niveau
international et avoir des résultats
avec une équipe qui me donne beaucoup de
plaisir et de chômeurs et heures et puis
il ya l'autre blanco
celui qui se font dans l'anonymat du
quotidien qui refait chez le poissonnier
le match du dimanche qui va au marché
faire les courses les jours de repos
bref le serge blanco l'enfant du pays la
fierté
celui qui plutôt vieille dame enfin le
blanco pour qui le haut niveau doit être
un exemple et c'est tout pour les
enfants qu'il adore ce blanco qui ne
veut pas polémiquer sur la couleur de sa
peau la politique politicienne
serge blanco qui accepte que l'on filme
son fils à la sortie de l'école n'est
pas à la maison
il veut absolument jouer la transparence
il n'y a pas d influence chez serge
blanco faire face et
au nom de
du sportif et c'est vrai que peut-être
la mer aussi me permet de m'évader et de
retrouver peut-être une certaine
sérénité
une sérénité dont il aura besoin samedi
contre l'angleterre la rose une fleur
qu'il apprécie à sa façon je préfère
l'appeler en ferait le même que les
ouvriers vivement samedi les résultats
du quarté de vincennes à l'arrivée le 11
le 13 le 19 et le 12 cinq francs dans
l'ordre rapporte 4899 rang et dans un
ordre différent 279 150 voilà dans un
instant sophie davant vous parlera du
temps de demain les dernières
informations tout à l'heure avec
philippe gassot mais auparavant édition
spéciale de claude sérillon
au menu la fraude fiscale demain 6h45
grand jézabel et une heure plus tard à
7h45 l'invité de gérard morin sera jean
claude gaudin candidats commencé à
marseille
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal bonsoir
admirateurs